prime minister I want to start talking
to you about the economy because that's
what people at home are really thinking
about Liz trust told me in September she
was prepared to be unpopular to push
through her economic plan are you
I think I demonstrated over the summer
that I'm prepared to be honest with the
country about the challenges we face and
to make the difficult decisions that are
required to fix them so I think people
can I think people can be reassured that
what they'll get from me is honesty
about challenges and I am prepared to do
difficult things I did that as
Chancellor and of course the government
is going to do what's right for the
long-term interesting country you accept
what you're going to do this week will
be unpopular well no I actually I mean I
I actually think that what people will
see on Thursday is that the government
is being upfront with people about the
challenges that we face it's right that
we get a grip of inflation it's right
that we limit the increases in mortgage
rates and that means having public
finances that are more sustainable and
that come on the confidence of
international markets that's also going
to be good for people at home but what
people will also see is that the way
we've gone about that is fair is
completed
on that but but the fact is your party
is now very unpopular you're over 20
points behind in the polls it might get
worse this week after you announce these
tax Rises and spending cuts we now know
that the conservative party's economic
experiment under Liz truss blew an
enormous 30 billion pound black hole in
the public finances this is I think like
the modern Tory parties black Wednesday
if you want to move on for this don't
you need to start by saying sorry to the
British people about what's just passed
on the steps of Downing Street when I
first became I said mistakes for me I
said mistakes were made and I said part
of the reason I became prime minister
was to fix them and what we have seen
what we have seen actually is much more
stability in the UK's financial position
in terms of what the UK is paying to
borrow money what's happened to the
pound that's a good and welcome
development it's now right that the
government delivers on those
expectations but I would say now but the
UK situation is stabilized we're here
talking to other leaders here in
Indonesia at the G20 these are Global
challenges the Legacy because there was
also a UK specific component as you know
in terms of what happened no one
apologized people can't pay their
mortgages potentially people can't are
struggling with food bills no one has
taken responsibility were you now say to
the British people let them say I'm
sorry they messed up I'm going to try
and fix it you said mistakes were made
but no has really taken responsibility
but I think it's really important that
people understand actually what's
happened since I became prime minister
and over the last few weeks is we've
actually seen all those UK specific
factors in terms of how much we borrow
what's happened to the power those have
all considerably improved and what we're
now facing are the same challenges that
many of the countries as well and I
don't think it's right to ignore those
because Energy prices are a phenomenon
that many countries are graduating with
inflation right now in Germany seriously
if I'm interrupt it seems to me that
you're more worried about heart and Liz
truss's feelings than you are about the
country and people being quite rightly
furious with the conservative party
because of what has just come to pass I
have to acknowledge that at least I I
think I spent I spent the summer talking
about the challenges that our country
faces talking about what I thought was
required to Grapple with those and fix
them to build a foundation which we
could provide jobs and growth and
prosperity for people over time so I
think people know where I stand on all
these issues and and now that I'm prime
minister I'm going to make sure that we
deliver on that because ultimately to
put this to bed though can you just say
you are sorry about what happened I know
it wasn't your doing but you are now
prime minister you do leave the party
and it is the Tory party that did this
and I've acknowledged from the steps of
Downing Street in the first statement
that I made to the country and
acknowledgment that mistakes were made
you don't want to apologize I get it
what I want to do now is fix them but
just anything you don't want to say
sorry about their mortgages you can't
sell their houses can't afford inflation
hikes okay what people grappling with
inflation or indeed mortgages want to
know is that we've got a plan okay and
we'll limit the increase in mortgage
rates that will bring inflation down and
I just think I think people can be
reassured that we will put a plan
together that will do okay and that's
what you'll see and just one compassion
and fairness is it fair to lift taxes
for everyone
I I think the chancellor has been very
clear about the challenges we face it's
right that we're upfront and honest with
the country about the scale of the
challenge we face but what we've also
said is that the way we go about that
will have fairness and compassionate
I'm not going to comment obviously you
wouldn't expect me to comment I'm not
I'm asking about the message he said
taxes will go up for everyone was Jeremy
Hunt wrong and and what you'll see from
the chancellor on Thursday is an
approach to solving this problem which I
believe most people actually at the end
of the day will recognize as being both
fair and compassionate in its approach
just two days and we'll see I can run
out of time uh you talked tough on China
during the leadership contest brand in
the country is the largest that to
Britain the world's security and
prosperity this century is that your
view now as prime minister or have you
changed your mind on China I'm very
clear that China poses a systemic
challenge to both our values and our
interests and it represents the single
biggest straight threat to our Economic
Security and that's why it's right that
we take the steps that are necessary to
protect ourselves against it is it a
threat or a challenge though well it is
a systemic challenge to our values and
interests it's also a very significant
threat to our Economic Security which is
why it's right that we take steps to
protect ourselves against that do you
think you can have a collaborative
relationship with President XI I think
our approach to China is one that is
very similar to our allies whether
that's America or Australia and Canada
all countries that I'm talking about
exactly this issue with while we're here
at the G20 Summit and I think it's an
indisputable fact of the global economy
that China is a big part of it and if we
want to solve big Global challenges like
public health like Russia and Ukraine
fixing the global economy or indeed
climate change it's important to have a
dialogue and to engage with China as
part of something and just finally
promise you said to me last night you
were hopeful you'd be the first prime
minister to meet president XI for a few
years for any British prime minister are
you going to meet him I'm hopeful that I
can I mean this as I said I think it's
important that we engage with people to
try and tackle some of these shared
challenges and I'm here to talk to
people and that's what I hope is
possible prime minister thank you very
much thank you very much